homenaje clamor de justicia en el décimo
aniversario miles de kurdos marcharon en
varias ciudades de Francia en honor a
las tres activistas kurdas asesinadas
del 9 de enero de 2013 en París
estamos aquí para pedir justicia y
verdad sobre este caso que tuvo lugar en
2013 pedimos al Estado francés que lo
aclare que arroje luz sobre él porque
sabemos que la implicación de los
servicios secretos turcos había quedado
demostrado Durante los procedimientos
judiciales
los activistas kurdos de Francia donde
reside la segunda comunidad más grande
en Europa después de Alemania reclaman
la implicación del Estado Turco en los
ataques pero las investigaciones se ven
entorpecidas por la falta de acceso a
los documentos secretos que París se
niega a desclasificar además el
principal sospechoso de nacionalidad
turca abdula o calan murió en prisión
poco antes de ser juzgado en 2016
10 años con esta reivindicación y
tristemente en este tiempo ha habido
tres asesinatos por eso la lucha debe
ser aún mayor nuestras exigencias deben
ser aún más fuertes
y es que la marcha se produce apenas dos
semanas después del triple asesinato de
tres cursos en un centro cultural de
París a pocos minutos a pie del lugar de
los tiroteos de 2013 Si se hubiera
resuelto el caso de 2013 Quizá el
incidente de 2022 no habría ocurrido Así
que los kurdos están solos Francia debe
rendir cuentas a los kurdos los kurdos
piden al Estado francés verdad y
Justicia para sus Mártires pero se
siente en una vez más desprotegidos por
el país que los acoge